last week a huge rust twitch rivals
tournament involving north american and
spanish streamers imploded in a big way
the spanish streamers accused twitch of
rigging the game in the north americans
favor while they themselves were accused
of inciting racism streamers like
disguise toast sqc and shroud have now
weighed in on what might be one of the
most insane twitch stories of the year
here's how it happened
all right first off rust is a
multiplayer survival game where players
gather resources craft weapons build
bases and fight each other in an open
world on persistent servers it sounds
simple but it's absolutely captivated
twitch for the past couple of years
which has culminated in this recent
twitch rivals event and it was massive
there were 14 north american streamers
versus 40 streamers from spain and latin
america team north america led by
disguise toast faced off against the
spanish-speaking team led by alex by 11.
team north america also featured big
streamers like xqc tarik and shroud the
battle was to take place on vanilla rust
servers for 24 hours starting in the
primitive era teams could earn points by
eliminating players and cashing in their
dog tags hackable crates neutral bases
and npcs could also drop dog tags the
team with the most dog tags at the end
would win simple in the beginning the
tournament delivered the typically
chaotic content that russ fans are
familiar with he seems to have done more
damage to the actual elliot
yeah so they're gonna fall back real
quick because
thankfully they can't be shot at here
you can just hear the bottom right in
spanish right now but this is a safe
zone so if anyone tries
me i ram you but as the tournament
progressed things took a negative twist
early on the na team destroyed the
spanish team's twig base which went
against the rule of not touching
buildings in your opponent's base square
admins were called in later that day the
spanish hit na back hard destroying a
lot of bags and loot in their base
because north america had left a lot of
their doors open admins were once again
called in and attempted to find a middle
ground between the two but this sort of
squabbling really came to a head when
disguised toast north america's team
captain was accused by the spanish of
cheating it all stemmed from one clip in
particular in which an mp5 appeared to
spawn out of toast's body and land
behind him
oh do not step into bush thank you
mysterious admin guns spawning out of
thin air and players then thanking the
admins for them definitely raised a few
eyebrows in the spanish community toast
was accused of cheating and the admins
of helping the north american side one
spanish streamer riccotti said there was
an embarrassing lack of respect and that
the tournament was disastrously
organized as the clip began to rack up
thousands of views toast pulled it up on
his stream to explain his side of things
it's in my hand
what am i gonna do with two mp5s and you
know what's the worst part
look at the top left
the event was over
25k to 5k
this was after the spanish team
announced they were quitting that's the
thing people are complaining about an
out of context clip which actually gives
context in the clip as well because you
can see the score on the top left and
you can see the gun in my hand so even
out of contacts
there was
contacts and that was still enough to
get them to accuse the admins of
cheating now that might seem like a
perfectly reasonable explanation right
the game was over he already had that
particular gun in his hands so there was
no way that this could have affected the
outcome of the tournament which again
was already over right but that wasn't
the only accusation that came from the
spanish side in a twitter thread the
spanish captain listed a number of
issues that he had with the tournament
these included the north american
streamers crafting pistols and grenades
when they should have only had primitive
tech that they refused to return items
to them and that they duplicated the
spanish team's heli later that day
twitch rivals announced something that
many people had seen coming by this
point they said on twitter that the
tournament was ending early and that
team disguised toast would be taking
home the win it was a forfeit from the
spanish side and the victory didn't
taste too sweet for a lot of north
american streamers for a lot of them
they felt the whole thing was
kind of bull we're not having a meeting
streaming it or telling people to quit
pretty much
good for them
because they're getting ready they think
we're being unfair again
unfair that we're so good what do you
think these people will be invited to no
and no i hope like
you're just like no no no the event
that's a really bad look for
all those involved
no i don't think they'll be invited
again maybe some of them the people that
weren't doing that people that actually
cared about it sure i think they should
get invited back damn that is a poor
sportsmanship for sure from them holy
kind of embarrassing honestly
yeah but
whatever whatever but they were far
darker accusations that have been
building since day two far worse than
just time wasting some north american
streamers such as mendo called out
spanish viewers for making racist
remarks in the north american streamers
chats
[Music]
a day after the event ended toast went
on stream to talk about the whole
situation and go through some unbanned
requests it was then that he came across
one particularly disturbing comment it
is not known if you are a gringo
chinese or korean
you don't even have a garbage identity
well i can understand why he's confused
because i am both chinese and korean
according to my most recent dna test
toast handled the whole situation
incredibly gracefully given the
circumstances as the team captain he
took the brunt of a lot of this and
don't forget he was the one who
initially approached twitch with the
idea for this particular event even
though he got some pretty nasty comments
thrown his way he still said there were
things that could be improved for next
time to make the spanish streamers feel
like the environment is more fair
because in his own words if there's no
content everybody loses and it's in
twitch's best interest to make sure that
this kind of thing doesn't happen too
one other thing that toast talked about
was the amount of money that twitch had
put into this event there was a hundred
thousand dollars in the price pool and
another hundred thousand into production
to put it simply they don't want teams
just dropping out early from tournaments
that they put almost a quarter of a
million dollars into that's just bad
business as they said in their twitter
post they're going to clarify rules in
the future to prevent confusion and also
reevaluate their format two issues that
seem to be the roots of a lot of the
problems it's difficult with a game like
rust because a lot of these rules are
hard to enforce rules like not going
more than two doors deep into a person's
base can only really be kept by a
gentleman's agreement unless you want to
retroactively vod review every streamer
but one issue that looms larger than the
rest are the accusations of racism
twitch hasn't addressed these directly
but for many people it tainted what was
otherwise a pretty entertaining twitch
rivals
[Music]
you